[Musique]
c'est la journée sans portable
il faut c'est ne plus avoir de portable
il ya cette table ici il va falloir
envoyer son portable le plus loin
possible
ah ouais faut pas chercher qu'il ya une
bassine d'eau derrière on n'a jamais
arrêté
mais c'est ça non mais très fausse à
celui qui sera le plus loin là j'ai
couru y aura des aigles y aura des
éliminés il y aura deux éliminés par
portable je le dis les deux celui qui
serait le plus loin la fin on gagnera le
scooter ce sera lui
il sera gravé à son nom servir si le
scooter c'est bella il y aura marqué
benhaim spécial boytchev hockey des
séries alors là les portes à mme soula
et donc à la fin du jeu neuf communes
portable un courant un scooter est
obligé de l'envoyer fort tg5 vous dit
j'ai envie de perdre le scooter et je
fais ça ou bien auprès joie risque et
vous y attend à nouveau en question et
je serai glisse beaucoup par alors moi
je peux pas vous dire j'ai pas essayé
il n'ya jamais décès ici c'est parti
pour le premier tour et je joue avec
vous amènera vous êtes vous avez 3
portable ou pas du tout su gérer un
portable saisi un couteau et regardez là
celui d'aujourd'hui c'est pas la
dernière générat sérum ou vrai portable
doumali ok voilà les plus jeunes et plus
portable ce soir à beaucoup de gens qui
seront tristes parle beaucoup d'enfants
qui pleurait c'est vrai alors que dany
tu l arbitre attention ni bas premier
tour qui durera deux éliminés les emails
et naïm tu commences attend à ce que je
sois stratège mais là il me faut plus
trop stratège oui ça va tout changer un
peu c'est pour y aller mais débutante
lena
laraque castaldi les passants tentent
encore portal
dès qu'on met your mother fourche harry
potter vous inquiétez pas voilà on a
remis la bassine chez moi alors castaldi
éliminer la deuxième menace pour la
suite at il pas inquiète pas tu peux
gagner vous jugerez d éliminer ces
savoirs dont prenez vos portables on a
les deux éliminés pour l'instant c'est
castaldi va jama et jean michel maire
dont j'ai vu le loup de l'humour vous
aime toujours les chéris c'est reparti
basso qui était présent mais on y va on
commence avec elle une panne et kerry
vas-y
je vous rappelle que le dernier qui
restera gagnera le scooter au late show
p vas-y agathe passer un cap
hagarde
il est dans l'eau je joue là bas tu peux
te réveiller à temps merci alors il ya
déjà eu des lives in et sagat agathe
pouvez vous mettre du côté de jean
michel et 2 et 2 3 1 4 avec jean-michel
et benjamin magath avec maxime dillies
je joue avec vous c'est le point sa tour
allez c'est parti qui m'intéresse
allez on y va on démarre avec pas mal de
belote et plus loin à la baisse comme ça
sinon on y lit pas un délit on est plus
que six on est plutôt pas mal ça allez
vas-y ben ouais c'est bien je n'ai pas
joué je suis encore là il faut bien que
j'anime bien c'est une savent si c'est
monsieur qui gagne le scooter sera comme
sur ebay dans un quart de ces web cwa
habib la maxime talbot a honoré le coup
de sifflet vois je te remercie les deux
les deux éliminés les 2000 reste plus
que quatre c'est qu'ils seraient là
c'est moi c'est kelly et maxime éliminé
fruitdealer va se jouer entre géraldine
allez on y va les ravinois d'ivoire par
les yeux fermés et maintenant j'attends
son g1 il y aura un éliminé à chaque
fois à l'essai sur ses appuis toi sur
lui et payet l'allemand est annie morel
vous aimez la mode il se dit c'est deus
total attendent à toi tu attends j'ai
pas dit que c'était toi qui joues
chifoumi tafer 6 pierre feuille ciseaux
ses toiles très tôt hier près de chez
toi le plus beau job et que tu choisis
csu 2e rei pousse la pousse d'amis phase
iv les milieux sénat pas attention à
scooter a gagné ne prend pas trop de
risques
rawan tribunal mais présent quand même
bon c'est tes enfants
bon ça toulouse face à tant pis pour sa
thèse en face à face aux jeunes en fait
les enfants annonce au maroc
c'est beau ce cas-là féminine laisse moi
te faire une coupure pub projet tease
maman
joue à des tas a levé - cette musique je
le diane je t'amène à 2000 derrière tu
me tiens comme le ghana de vilain coup
tu nous tiens comme ça derrière ben on
laisse le conduiront ça m'arrange pas du
tout ça comme à vous et dieu je suis
derrière ah oui non non non personne
derrière pearson en sautoir chacun sait
chez soi
attention benhaim et très bon l'instant
le scooter et a beau jouer alors c'est
son anniversaire dans quelques épisodes
et toi non mais il s'en va alors lui les
jouets notre ami le scooter il sera à
vous direct attendez attendez attendez
est-ce qu'on a quelqu'un de téléphone
qui me joue avec nous pour le scooter on
a quelqu'un va jouer avec nous allons à
l'eau dit jouable et l'eau oui bonsoir
ma chérie comment tu t'appelles de
belleville à sa vague idée de la machine
oui car ma super je suis content de
t'avoir fait c'est moi la vie continue
quoi bon an mal an alors oui j'ai donné
mes enfants qui regardent la télé en
même temps nous a pas de ligue 1 le
paris paris à d'abord été juste à côté
là tu fais quoi dans la vie alors j'ai
toujours tu faisais mon enfant la
corrida il a quel âge il a deux ans
ailier comme elle sait comment il
s'appelle tel voeu tôt
il a bien réagi dans les fringues dieu
bénisse ces lembras le shérif qu'il
embrasse alors à ton avis est-ce que tu
va peut-être pouvoir repartir avec le
scooter également bas peut-être alors la
question est simple est-ce que tu penses
que c'est matthieu delormeau qui va
gagner ou valérie bénaïm valérie sachant
que valérie est déjà là ouais mais je ne
tends valérie séné vous qui connaissez
si bien les règles
voyez question si je joue en diagonale
et que je dégage valérie totalement de
la table que je reste mais vous avez
gagné
bah ouais je serai pas faire ça tu
ressembles à ce que tu veux t'en dit
bryant votre chéri avec no way à dany
brillant tu lui fais un petit coucou
coucou à lui verser en fait ce qu'on lui
dit coucou savoir dire est qu'elle n'a
pas l'imposer
il ya karine le marchand car les matches
et rit on a beaucoup beaucoup de
dossiers on aura aussi isabelle
morini-bosc aussi qu'il va venir nous
voir les chiffres on va revenir pour
l'émission d'hier à batna - mathieu
aller battue où tu as perdu un scooter
m'a serré la télé champ attention à
temps et si on attend se dégage
quoi tu es prêt ouais ça va bon il va s
vidéo on y va
doit-on quelles sont ses vrais d'accord
il a droit ma chérie balle orange
batamack smartphones tout via smartphone
ma chérie est organisé sur veille
matthieu delormeau gadier les scooters
cependant il est bon sens les collèges